an important weapon for fighting
aggressive cancers now has a new promise
for many patients in no therapy it's a
treatment that triggers a body's own
defense system to fight cancerous cells
mutations now the FDA's just expanded
the approved uses for immunotherapy drug
that has successfully treated certain
lung cancers and melanoma former
President Jimmy Carter took the drug a
few months later he reported that he was
cancer-free our doctor David agus is
head of the USC westside cancer center
in Los Angeles David good morning I
remember Gail being high people being
very excited and very encouraged by
Jimmy Carter's progress tell us exactly
how it works first tell me how to
pronounce it immunotherapy immunotherapy
and this drug get a load of this the
drug we're talking about with the new
FDA approval is called Pembrey lism AB
so obviously rolls off the tongue or
Kate ruda every cancer cell is born with
it don't eat me signal on its surface
and the immune system can't recognize it
and what these drugs do is they block
that don't eat me signal to allow the
immune system to be activated and attack
the cancer and it's a whole new weapon
in our arsenal that's really had
tremendous advances David it sounds like
immuno therapy challenges the idea that
cancer should be treated by body part
and instead says cancer should be
treated by the can't type of cancer is
that right yeah it's so amazing is that
last week for the first time ever the
FDA approved a drug not by body part
breast lung colon but by what was the
molecular defect in this case they had a
particular gene that allowed DNA to
repair itself that was turned off or
faulty and there were a lot of DNA
errors and then the immune system
recognized them and attacked it so this
really was in new advanced you know in
the 1800s in Germany we started to
categorize cancer by body part and
finally we're changing David there was a
sport page store in The Washington Post
over the weekend about a 23 year old
woman who had colon cancer a very bad
case of colon cancer
somehow luckily she got in touch with a
program that was underway at Johns
Hopkins and talked to the geneticists
that get over here right away
and it was exactly that result they
found out it had not to do it had to do
with a particular tumor not the location
in the body I mean are we going to see
this kind of thing as
I just told you what you just talked
about Jimmy Carter spreading across all
cancers
yeah it's about four to five percent of
all cancers and this particular woman
actually inherited a DNA defect from her
mother where it had the DNA repair genes
turned off and so she was very lucky in
that Bert vogelstein and his group at
Hopkins had done remarkable work to
identify this as a possible treatment
with immunotherapy so how do you know if
it's a good option for a cancer patient
what should we be asking well every
cancer patient should go to their doctor
and say what are the options and ask is
immunotherapy an option and more and
more it's becoming an option for lung
cancers for obviously colon cancer in
this case for endometrial cancers from
melanoma for kidney cancers we're
learning how to use it better and
literally every few months we're
learning a new indication David you say
it's not a cure though why is that well
it turns off the I mean the immune
system turns off the cancer and over
time though in almost all cases the
cancer comes back and so it buys one to
two to three years it does have side
effects but it certainly buys time it
Papes it in patients who many times have
no other hope dr. David agus thanks as
always